one of hurricane Michels survivors says
his city looks like an atomic bomb hit
at Florida's panhandle is one huge
disaster zone after a catastrophic winds
heavy rain and devastating storm surge
Michael was the third most powerful
hurricane ever to make landfall on the
United States mainland the storm is
being blamed for at least two deaths
more than 650,000 homes and businesses
in the southeast have no electricity
Michael is now a tropical storm hitting
the Carolinas with heavy downpours and
threatening to cause tornadoes it's
moving northeast with top winds of 50
miles per hour
our team of Correspondence is spread
across the region in CBS Evening News
anchor Jeff Glor is leading our coverage
from Panama City Beach Florida
Jeff good morning Vienna good morning to
you this is just a small bit of what we
are seeing across the Florida Panhandle
this morning we're in Panama City Beach
where we got blasted by Michael
yesterday you can see this that's what
was a Food Mart and gas station the
steel beams and the concrete remains the
rest of it in a very rough shape Michael
came ashore with winds topping out at
155 miles an hour just 2 miles an hour
short of a cat5 and so now this morning
is all about getting out to assess the
damage and try to recover with a howling
merciless violence hurricane Michael
sliced into the Florida Panhandle the
storm devastated coastal communities as
the lowest pressure hurricane to strike
the US mainland since 1969 and we'll get
through this together
hurricane Michael could not break
Florida the destruction is widespread in
Panama City the storm appeared to do its
worst some houses and businesses are
unrecognizable the roof of the school
gymnasium torn open an entire freight
train pushed off the rails
Sabrina Marshall was inside her home as
parts were torn away from her
blew down trees and tangled powerlines
have made many streets impassable I was
in a bunker almost a bunker
ad yes prayers at Tyndall Air Force Base
near Panama City the damage is extensive
an entire roof was stripped from an
aircraft hangar overturned trucks and
debris litter the tarmac the base
commander ordered an evacuation on
Monday Michael made landfall in Florida
shortly before 1:00 p.m.
hitting the tourist town of Mexico Beach
powerful winds punished the coastline
ripping tops from buildings and sending
them airborne like a jet engine I mean
the winds just super super high-pitched
you could feel it in your ears like the
pressure just changing in and out
officials say it could take months if
not years to repair the damage if you've
never experienced a hurricane or major
storm trust me this is something that
you never want to go through one of the
challenges one of the big challenges is
people head out this morning and try to
figure out how bad it all is is all of
the downed power lines as we've seen and
trying to navigate those or just stay
away from those because it remains such
a danger this morning president Trump is
expected to visit this area early next
week
Gael back to you hey Jeff I watched you
last night it was pretty dicey for you
and the crew what stands out to you this
morning it's the sounds I think gale of
what you heard when we had to go inside
this the shrieking howls the whistling
of the storm that was trying to take
down every window and wall that it could
really does look like something out of a
movie a very scary movie thank you very
much Jeff for reporting from Florida